Das ist "Mona mittendrin".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Aufziehen kann man lernen.
Das sind meine Compagnons
für die nächsten drei Tage:
die Jungs vom Zivilschutz.
Das ist etwas Neues.
Zivilschutz ...
Ist das ein Downgrade fürs Ego?
So quasi die ...
- Nein, überhaupt nicht.
... die ins Militär gehen
und der Zivilschutz als Gurkentruppe.
Das ist das, was man hört.
Anfangs fühlte man sich so.
Das muss ich ehrlich sagen.
- Bei dir?
Ja, bei mir. Ich kann nicht
für die anderen sprechen.
Bis ich merkte, was wir machen.
Ich bin jetzt zufrieden, wie es ist.
Weil du sagst,
dass es Sinn macht, was ihr macht?
Genau.
Ich bin ja freiwillig hier.
Ich wollte kein Militär machen.
Warum?
- Und ich hatte noch Asthma.
Weil ich
keinen Krieg ausführen wollte.
Ich fand, das können andere machen.
Nicht ich.
Ich bin freiwillig im Zivilschutz.
Dann gehen wir.
- Ja.
Viel Erfolg.
Ihr habt ja noch Zeit.
Ihr müsst nichts einrichten.
Unsere Aufgabe: Die Leute in 30 Min.
durch den Impfparcours schleusen.
Der Eingang, wo wir reinkamen.
- Ja.
Sie kommen bitte zu mir.
- Entschuldigung. Das sog. Foyer.
Hier werden Masken verteilt.
Lief alles gut?
- Ja, super.
Was ist dein Job?
- Die Leute nach vorne zu bringen
und der Reihe nach aufzurufen,
damit alle zufrieden sind.
Wie sind sie?
- Wir haben gerade Lob gekriegt.
Darüber sind wir froh.
Sie können beim Kollegen einhängen.
- Danke schön.
Bitte schön.
- Wir gehen da rüber.
Er macht die Zuweisung
in die zwei Administrationszimmer.
Dort findet die erste Erfassung
am PC statt.
Was war das?- Das ist ein Zeichen
für meinen Kollegen.
Wir versuchen,
Paare zusammenzulassen,
damit sie nebeneinander
die Registrierung machen können
und auch zusammen impfen können.
Ich gebe ihm Zeichen, in
welchem Zimmer wie viel Platz ist.
Hier könnte ein Paar kommen
oder wir verteilen einen und einen.
Damit er weiss,
wie viele Leute er reinlassen kann,
damit es hier keinen Stau gibt.
- Ja.
Wie viele Impfungen am Tag sind es?
- Rund 350 Impfungen pro Tag.
Geimpft?
- Geimpft.
Hallo miteinander.
- Grüezi.- Hallo zusammen.
Wir schauen frech rein.
- Wir kompilieren noch.
Er ist blutverdünnt,
darum geht es länger.
Aber ich glaube, es ist gut.
- Ja, ja. Danke schön.
Sie können sich anziehen
und gehen 15 Min. in den Ruheraum.
Das ist er jetzt.
- Genau.
Der Moderna-Impfstoff,
den wir momentan haben.
Aus dieser Ampulle
gewinnen wir zehn bis elf Impfdosen.
Auf was muss man achten?
Ich finde es wichtig,
dass man die Leute erfasst.
Es hat doch
einen starken Durchfluss.
Man sieht den Leuten meistens an,
ob sie Angst oder Respekt haben.
Was für Bedenken haben sie?
- Die Spätfolgen.
Oder die Nebenwirkungen,
die noch nicht ganz klar sind.
Das müssen wir ehrlicherweise sagen.
Das wissen wir noch nicht.
Wir müssen schon wieder raus.
Da wartet schon wieder jemand.
Es muss weitergehen.
"Bitte warten! Sie werden zugeteilt."
Grüezi miteinander.
Sie hatten gerade die Impfung, oder?
Gerade vorher war ich in der Kabine.
Was ist das für ein Moment für Sie,
jetzt, da Sie
die erste Corona-Impfung haben?
Ich hatte im April Corona.
- Ah, Sie hatten es schon?
Ja, zwei Wochen im künstlichen Koma.
- Okay.
Wow!
- Ja.
Da wusste man nicht ...
... ob links oder rechts, wollen Sie
sagen? Ja, ich auch nicht.
War es so?
- Ja, ja.
Okay.
- Das wurde nachher wieder gut.
Ich wünsche Ihnen gute Gesundheit.
- Danke schön.
* Ruhige Musik *
Geimpft werden Personen ab 75 und
Leute mit schweren Vorerkrankungen.
Wir fragen nach dem Namen
und der Uhrzeit des Termins.
Das gleichen wir
mit dem Geburtsdatum ab.
Jetzt kommt der Termin von 10.20 Uhr.
Da sind schon alle hier.
Das ist super.
Ich beginne bei Ihnen. Name?
- Menegini.
Menegini. Jawohl.
- Jawohl, ja.
8.7.1950.
- Das ist so.
Danke, dann dürfen Sie reingehen.
- Danke.
Tscharner ...
Äh ... Siehst du es?
Sie sind erst ...
- Sie müssen warten. 10.20 Uhr.
Darf er rein?
- Sie können drinnen warten.
Dort drin ist es etwas geschützter.
Wer den Termin um 10.40 Uhr oder
später hat, wartet bitte im Zelt.
Also, komm, gehen wir ins Zelt.
Ihr kommt später dran.
Burger, genau.
Ich bräuchte noch das Geburtsdatum.
Ging alles gut?
- Ja, ja.
Jeder hier hat seine eigene
Geschichte mit Corona - auch Nderim.
Er ist einer
von rund 2'000 Zivilschützern,
die in dieser Woche in der Schweiz
wegen Corona im Einsatz stehen.
Wie hast du
die Corona-Pandemie überstanden?
Was machte das mit dir
und deiner Familie?
Mein Bruder wurde angesteckt
und war auch im Spital.
Als ich das bei ihm sah,
wie er darunter litt,
verstand ich auch,
dass das nicht so ohne ist.
Er hat wirklich ...
- Er war fünf Tage im Spital.
Er hat es cool überstanden.
Was ich wirklich mitnehme:
Du musst wertschätzen,
wie gesund du bist.
Nicht einfach leben und so:
"Ja, ja, das kann passieren."
Man sollte
wirklich alles wertschätzen.
So, ade! Eine gute Zeit!
- Auf Wiedersehen!
Wir kommen auch in die Pause.
Mona, ich habe ein Geschenk
für dich.- Für mich?
Habe ich ihn schon verdient?
- Ja, sicher hast du ihn verdient.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
ich stand eher im Weg rum,
als wirklich etwas zu machen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich würde ihn sonst auch nehmen.
Können wir die verschiedenen Bereiche
kurz aufzählen?
Was ist da?- IT-Bereich.
- Dienstleistung.
Reinigungsbranche.
- Ja, Reinigung.
Auch IT-Branche.- IT.
- Informatik, Robotik.
Informatik.
- Ingenieurbüro für Haustechnik.
Treuhandbüro.
- Ein Querschnitt der Gesellschaft.
Und zusammen
stemmt ihr ein Impfzentrum.
Das ist cool. Ihr kommt
mit einer Generation in Kontakt,
die ihr sonst
nur von den Grosseltern kennt.
Smalltalkmässig mit den älteren
Leuten ist das noch interessant.
Man hört viel von früher,
wie es war.
Einige würden uns am liebsten
umarmen und nicht mehr loslassen.
Darf ich?
- Ich werde schon empfangen.
Genau. Genau. Wie ist Ihr Name?
Margrit Enzler.
- Frau Enzler.
Soll ich bei Ihnen einhängen?
- Es geht gut selbstständig.
Gut.
- Einfach nicht so schnell.
Dann begleite ich Sie.
Ich bin da, falls etwas ist.
Tipptopp.
- Ja, danke schön.
Hier nach hinten.
Wie war Ihr Jahr mit Corona?
Wie sah das aus?
Seit Mitte März
war ich in keinem Laden mehr.
Meine Tochter und mein Schwiegersohn
kaufen einmal pro Woche
für mich ein -
gemäss meiner Wunschliste.
Dann waren Sie jetzt
ein Jahr nicht mehr draussen?
Im Juli war ich noch im Spital.
- Ja.
Und dann
ein zweiter Spitalaufenthalt.
Dann vier Wochen Reha.
So war ich doch
etwas unter den Leuten.
Doch, doch, das ist jetzt ...
Ade.
- Adieu miteinander. Danke.
Danke auch.
Sind Sie alleine zu Hause?
Ich bin seit zwei Jahren verwitwet.
- Ja. Ja.
Gab es Momente, in denen Sie dachten,
es falle Ihnen
die Decke auf den Kopf?
Nicht wirklich. Ich konnte mich
jeweils selber ablenken.
Und etwas raus ...
Sie haben Mühe mit Gehen.
Auf dem Balkon.- Ja?
- Ich habe einen langen Balkon.
Dann machten Sie dort ...
- ... Touren.
Einfach ein paarmal die ganze Runde.
- Ja.
Sie scheinen so positiv zu sein.
Gibt es einen Tipp dafür?
Ich glaube, mit jedem
schwierigen Fall, den man erlebt,
wird man auch wieder etwas stärker.
Wissen Sie, ich denke immer:
"Wenn ich 78 Jahre leben konnte ...
... ist das auch etwas."
Viele sind in dem Alter
nicht mehr da.
So sehe ich das.
- Ja.
Dass ich dankbar bin
für alles Schwierige,
das ich überleben konnte.
Operationen
und gesundheitliche Einbrüche.
Ja.
Es freut mich, wenn Sie
wieder um das Haus gehen können,
anstatt nur auf dem Balkon.
- Das ist Dora, meine Nachbarin.
Holen Sie sie ab? Alles Gute.
- Ihnen auch.
Auf Wiedersehen miteinander.
Auf Wiedersehen.
Sie können gerne ...
Ich dachte, sie käme raus.
Ging alles gut?
- Tipptopp.- Ein Glückstag.
Sicher?
- Ja.- Ich bin auch froh.
Es gefiel uns so gut,
wir kommen nochmals.
Super.
- Wirklich, der ganze Ablauf ...
Vielen Dank.
- Wirklich super.
Jetzt sieht man
den logistischen Hintergrund
und was es alles braucht,
damit das läuft.- Das ist so.
Bleiben Sie gesund! Bis in 30 Tagen.
- Ade.- Darum sind wir da.
Genau, so ist es. Eine gute Zeit!
- Auf Wiedersehen.
Danke, gleichfalls.
- Auf Wiedersehen!
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Hektik lässt gegen Abend nach,
aber die Anspannung bleibt.
Sorry, wie viele Impfungen
hast du noch? Keine mehr.
Besonders bei Markus Wopmann,
dem medizinischen Leiter
des Impfzentrums.
Der ehemalige Kinderarzt
muss darauf achten,
dass jede übrig gebliebene Spritze
noch einen Arm findet.
Wie viele
sind noch nicht reingekommen?
Ja ...
16.50 Uhr fehlt noch eine Person.
Und dann ist 16.30 Uhr noch eine,
die noch nicht aufgetaucht ist.
Die kommt wohl nicht mehr. Sagen wir
eine bis maximal zwei Personen.
Ganz genau, der Rest ist erledigt.
Du warst Kinderarzt,
bist pensioniert
und jetzt trittst du hier
ein Monsterprojekt an.
Ja, ich kam über Nacht dazu.
Ich sagte, sie hätten viel zu tun
mit der Impfsache
und sie meinten,
ich könne das direkt übernehmen.
Da fand ich: "Ja, gut."
Impfen gehört ja zum Handwerk
des Kinderarztes.
Es ist eine spannende Sache.
Wenn man von Grund auf
ein Impfzentrum aufbauen muss:
Welche Dinge haben dir da
Bauchschmerzen bereitet?
Die Hauptchallenge ist
die Verfügbarkeit des Impfstoffs.
Plötzlich wurde von einem Impfstoff
doch nur die Hälfte geliefert.
Das stellt die ganze Planung um.
Letzte Woche
waren wir etwas frustriert.
Wir hatten einen Tiefpunkt
mit den Impfstoffen.
Der Betrieb lief auf einem Viertel,
weil Impfstoff fehlte.
Schauen wir, ob es noch Leute hat.
Müssen Sie beide
noch geimpft werden?
Zwei.
Okay. Müssen Sie
noch geimpft werden?- Nein.
Keine Impfung.
Wie viele hast du noch?
Eine Person und eine Impfung.
- Dann keine mehr?
Auch alles ausgeschossen.
- Da drin hat es null?
Also ... Es sind jetzt
noch zwei Leute, die geimpft werden.
Dann hat sie auch nichts mehr.
- Dann ist fertig.
Wir haben noch zwei Impfungen
und vier Leute, die kommen.
Wir müssen also eine Ampulle öffnen
und noch Leute holen.
Genau.
- Sagen wir es vorne.
Zieht bitte eine auf
und wir telefonieren direkt.
Schlüssel?
- Der Schlüssel, ja.
Unser Tresorschlüssel. Ist gut.
Ich telefoniere mal.
Da ist Wopmann,
Impfzentrum Königsfelden, grüezi.
Wir hätten
noch übrig gebliebene Impfungen.
Könnten Sie
möglichst schnell herkommen?
So, einen haben wir.
Beim Aufbieten wird er
von seinem Sohn Lukas unterstützt.
Er ist der Standortleiter
des Impfzentrums Windisch.
Aufgezogene Impfungen
kann man nicht über Nacht behalten.
Wir hätten noch Impfungen
in Königsfelden.
Wenn Sie möglichst schnell vor-
beikommen, könnten wir Sie impfen.
Sie freuen sich alle.
- Alles Risikopatienten?
Nein,
die arbeiten alle mit Patienten.
Ah, Pflegepersonal?
Pflegepersonal, Arzt, Röntgen ...
... Orthopädie -
Leute, die mit Patienten arbeiten.
Nicht mehr Hochrisikopersonal.
Die konnten wir
im ersten Schritt impfen.
Jetzt kommt
das Mittelrisikopersonal.
Aber sicher Leute,
die mit Patienten Kontakt haben,
nicht Verwaltungsangestellte
oder so.
Da durch.
- Ich hole die Impfdosen.
* Ruhige Musik *
An diesem Tag wurde keine Spritze
umsonst aufgezogen.
Kramer, Heinz.
- Ja.
Rölli, Fabienne.
Lüthi, Käthi.- Ja.
- Kistler, Irene.- Ja.
Wir haben heute 353 Patienten
im System, die wir erwarten können.
Wie gestern:
Moderna, nur Erstimpfungen.
Vielleicht für die Neuen,
die das noch nicht wissen:
Die Namen sind einfach zu merken:
Lukas Wopmann und Markus Wopmann.
Wir sind verwandt.
* Lachen *
Er ist der administrative
bzw. Standortleiter,
ich bin der ärztliche Leiter.
Gut, dann legen wir los.
Einen schönen Tag.
Tag für Tag sind im Impfzentrum
neue Leute im Einsatz.
Guten Morgen. Können Sie mir
Ihren Namen sagen?- Jud.
Frau Jud. Jawohl, das ist wunderbar.
- Wunderbar.
Sie können dort drin warten.
Es geht ...
- Ich gehe etwas laufen.
Rund eine halbe Stunde, denke ich.
- Genau, ca. 30, 35 Min.
Das ist nicht so gut organisiert.
Wir sind ein Ehepaar und haben uns
in derselben Minute angemeldet,
ich komme aber erst
um 15.30 Uhr dran.- Heute?
Wir müssen zweimal
den ganzen Weg machen.
Heute um 15.30 Uhr?
Also, gehen Sie rein.
Das macht keinen Sinn.
Das hast du jetzt entschieden?
- Ja, das machen wir so.
Das ist abgesprochen.
- Er hatte den Termin um 15.30 Uhr
und fand das doof.
Und du sagst dann ...
Wir sehen ja,
dass es ältere Leute sind.
Die Belastung, zweimal
hierherzukommen, macht keinen Sinn.
Das machen wir nicht.
- Ja.
Ist gut. Es kommen noch mehr Leute.
Schnell die Hände desinfizieren.
- Zwei? Okay.
Kommen Sie nur näher. 8.20 Uhr?
Der Kollege nimmt Sie dann mit.
Jetzt habe ich dich ...
- Also, wir haben noch zwei ...
Da ist ja wirklich ... Also, hey.
Ich habe bei jedem Zahnarzttermin
länger gewartet
als hier vor dem Impfzentrum.
Grüezi miteinander!
Wer von Ihnen hat den Termin?
Heute ist es etwas ruhiger
als gestern.
Du gehst auf in dem Job, oder?
Ich bin ein offener Mensch.
Ich bin kein geschlossener Mensch
oder habe Hemmungen.
Der Ausgang ist hier.
Auf Wiedersehen. Eine schöne Zeit!
- Danke. Auf Wiedersehen!
Auf Wiedersehen!
Wir hatten vorgestern oder so
eine Dame, die 97 war.
Und die kam stolz rein.
Wir alle sind jung und sprechen von
Pandemie und dem Angestecktwerden.
Sie ist 97 und kam knallhart rein:
"Grüezi miteinander."
Sie holte die Impfung und ging.
Ich meine,
sie hat das auch überlebt.
Auf Wiedersehen und eine gute Zeit!
- Vielen Dank.
Ich bin nicht der Typ, der morgens
überlegt, was mir der Tag bringt.
Sondern: "Was gebe ich dem Tag?"
Das ist so mein Motto.
Und immer Kopf hoch,
sonst fällt die Krone runter.
Sein Optimismus tut gut.
Nderim - im normalen Leben Maurer
und dreifacher Familienvater.
Sie können gerne mit mir mitkommen.
Ist gut.
Haben Sie eine SMS
mit den Terminen erhalten?
Genau.
- Super. Dann stimmt das.
Da muss man sich keine Sorgen machen.
Grüezi, ich bin Mona.
- Brigitte.
Du fällst mir auf,
weil alle anderen 75 und älter sind.
Darf ich fragen, warum du hier bist?
- Ich bin Hochrisikopatientin.
Ich habe zwei Autoimmunerkrankungen.
Ich habe ein Attest, dass ich
auch schon früh geimpft werde.
Du wärst ganz ein einfaches Opfer
für Viren aller Art.
Auch für Corona.
- Grundsätzlich ja.
Es gab für mich
schon viele Einschränkungen.
Mein Partner wohnt z.B.
nicht im gleichen Haushalt wie ich.
Wir sahen uns nur sehr dezimiert.
Oder wenn, dann auch mit Maske.
Und ... Ja ...
Das war so unser Jahr.
Und meine Kinder
wohnen beide noch bei mir.- Ja.
Es gelten Vorsichtsmassnahmen.
Sie wissen, was machen,
wenn sie reinkommen:
Hände waschen, desinfizieren,
Kleider in die Wäsche ...
Ja, es sind einfach ...
- Ich stelle mir vor:
Wenn du jung bist,
siehst du ja deine Freunde.
Hatten sie nie Angst,
dass sie dir Corona bringen
und dich in Lebensgefahr bringen?
Luca hat seine drei, vier, fünf
guten Freunde und Freundinnen,
die er jeweils wieder traf.
Er kriegte dann mal Fieber
und Symptome.
Dort hatte er fast einen
Zusammenbruch und weinte nur noch.
"Mami, jetzt gefährde ich dich."
Und: "Wegen mir" usw.
Er war dann zum Glück negativ.
Ich muss aber sagen:
Viel daraus gelernt hat er nicht.
Ich verstehe es ein Stück weit.
Mit 19 auf alles zu verzichten,
nur weil du jetzt halt
eine Mutter zu Hause hast,
die gefährdet ist ... Ja.
Das ist ein mega Anspruch.
Das finde ich sehr schwierig.
Für alle Jungen.
- Ja.
Sie dürfen mit mir mitkommen.
- Danke schön.
Haben Sie Fragen
bezüglich der Impfung?
Mich nimmt wunder,
ob man sagen kann,
wie lange es nach
der zweiten Impfung etwa geht,
bis der Impfschutz wirklich da ist?
- Man sagt, rund zwei Wochen.
Okay.
Das ist das,
was man im Moment weiss.
Nach zwei Wochen sei sicher
der volle Schutz vorhanden.
Stich.
Aline
ist eine von elf Pflegefachpersonen,
die pro Tag im Einsatz stehen.
Sie hat sich freiwillig
für diese Arbeit gemeldet.
Ich sah auf Facebook einen Aufruf
des Kantonsspitals Baden.
Ich fühlte mich stark angesprochen.
Ich habe lange
auf dem Notfall gearbeitet.
Nach dem dritten Kind
hörte ich auf zu arbeiten.
Ich habe nicht mehr
an der Front gearbeitet und fand:
"Jetzt muss ich. Ich muss
etwas gegen die Pandemie machen."
Aus einem Pool von 300 Freiwilligen
kann das Impfzentrum Windisch
Leute aufbieten.
Die Bereitschaft, bei der grössten
Impfaktion der Schweiz mitzuhelfen,
sei gross.
Auch bei den Zivilschützern.
Sie sind zwar nicht freiwillig hier,
aber jeder ist voll bei der Sache.
Für einmal ist es eben keine Übung,
sondern ein richtiger Einsatz.
Es ist fast ein Jahrhundertereignis.
Es ist ... Ja ...
Als ich in der Primarschule war,
las man in den Geschichtsbüchern
über den Ersten
und Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ich behaupte,
dass man in den nächsten paar Jahren
von der Pandemie lesen wird.
Ein Teil davon sein zu können,
macht stolz.
Andererseits
hat es aber auch eine Wichtigkeit,
die sonst nicht so vorkommt.
- Ja.
Das Klischee der Gurkentruppe
bestätigt sich nicht.
Die einzige Gurke, die man findet,
ist die im Sandwich.
Wer hier im Impfzentrum arbeitet
und was hier abläuft,
steht unter besonderer Beobachtung
der Öffentlichkeit.
Darf ich euch stören?
- Herein. Hallo.
Euch sehe ich fast am wenigsten.
Ihr seid hier im Headquarter.
Oder überall, ja.
- Wie auch immer.
Ich hatte gestern Zeit,
mich etwas zu informieren.
Du hattest ja auch eine Schlagzeile,
als ihr das Zentrum aufgebaut habt.
Also, die Schlagzeile war, du hättest
dir eine Impfung erschlichen.
Was war da los?
Die Situation war,
dass kurz vor Weihnachten rauskam,
dass der Impfstoff
in der Schweiz zugelassen wird.
Dann baust du über die Festtage
ein Impfzentrum auf -
mit der Hektik und dem Stress,
der dazugehört.
Wir machten das in Baden und sahen,
dass wir einen Probelauf brauchten.
Dann sagte die Leiterin der Impf-
strategie im Kantonsspital Baden,
ich könne auch impfen,
weil ich über 65 bin.
Ja.
- Damals gingen wir davon aus,
dass Menschen über 65
Risikogruppe Nummer 1 seien.
Das bin ich. Und ich arbeite jetzt
mit vielen Leuten zusammen.
Dann liess ich mich impfen.
Und Neujahr kam der Bescheid des
Bundesrats, die Altersgrenze sei 75.
Dann kam die Schlagzeile,
der Chef des Impfzentrums habe sich
als Erster eine Impfung verpasst.
Das ist so das Thema
der Impfdrängler.
Oder alle erschleichen sich ...
Da zeigt sich schon,
dass eine grosse Anspannung da ist.
Alle wollen unbedingt
an die Impfung ran.
Das zeigt sich ja da.
Jede Form von Rationierung
ist irgendwie ungerecht.
Dann gibt es immer
einen Teil der Bevölkerung,
der sich ungerecht behandelt fühlt.
- Ja.
Es gibt keine gerechte Lösung.
Gerecht wird es, wenn du
Impfstoffe im Überfluss hast
und sagen kannst: "Jeder Mann,
jede Frau kann sich impfen lassen."
Das haben wir leider momentan nicht.
Unterstützt wird er
von seinem Sohn Lukas.
Der Ausbildner bei Swissport am
Flughafen ist zurzeit in Kurzarbeit.
Darum nahm er die Aufgabe
als Standortleiter im Impfzentrum an.
Striptease. So, also.
Es gibt einen Stich.
Schon vorbei.
Ich habe nicht mal etwas gemerkt.
Muss ich noch halten?
Ich sehe kaum,
wo ich gestochen habe.
Da kommt nicht viel.
- Nein.
Wie geht es Ihnen jetzt?
- Ja, nicht anders als vorher.
Also, ich spüre nichts.
* Er lacht. *
Wie alt sind Sie?
- 89.- 89.
Wie haben Sie entschieden,
ob Sie impfen wollen oder nicht?
Eigentlich zusammen,
meine Frau und ich.
Wir fanden, dass die Krankheit
bzw. was daraus entstehen kann,
schwerwiegend sein kann,
also lassen wir uns impfen.
Man möchte eben
auch in unserem Alter
noch etwas leben,
wenn es einem gut geht.
V.a. wieder
mit der Familie zusammen sein
und mit unseren Freunden.
Dass man wieder in die Stadt kann
und Theater schauen ...
... Veranstaltungen besuchen ...
... Leute treffen kann.
Das ist das.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ist das hier ein erster Schritt
zurück in die Normalität?
Die Hoffnung ist bei vielen gross.
Schaust du da, ich schaue hier.
Entschuldigung,
darf ich kurz schauen?
Du hast noch eine für die Dame?
- Eine wurde mir ausgelehnt.
Eine.
- Jetzt habe ich noch eine.
Hier ist noch eine.
- Da auch. Nach der Dame eine?
Nein. Aha ...
- Eine für einen neuen Patienten.
Gut, wir haben noch zwei.
Was ist deine Prognose?
Wettet ihr jeweils?
Das müssten wir einführen.
Ich sage vier.
Was sagst du?- Du sagst vier.
Ich sage, wir haben zwei.
Eine haben wir herbestellt.
Zwei musst du noch anrufen.
- Zwei können noch.
Rufst du an? Denen,
die mich anrufen, sage ich ab.
Ja. Ich mache zwei Telefonate.
- Wir haben nicht gewonnen.
Es ist der Mittelwert. Es sind drei.
- Drei?
Ich sagte vier und sie zwei.
Also, Beiler wurde geimpft.
Da ist Herr Hübel ...
- Ja.
Eine halbe Stunde herumtelefonieren,
um drei Impfungen zu platzieren.
Irgendwie absurd
und beeindruckend gleichzeitig.
Heute soll neuer Impfstoff
geliefert werden -
wenn alles planmässig läuft.
Manchmal ist es gut gefüllt,
manchmal nicht.
Noch schnell das Tenue erstellen?
- Das Tattoo zeigen.
* Lachen *
Hat er ein Tattoo?
Habt ihr keine Vorgesetzten,
die kurz das Tenue kontrollieren?
- Wir sind selbstständig.
Ah, okay.
Kannst du ... Ist bei mir gut?
Ich muss raus in den Einsatz.
- Darf ich schnell? So.
Tipptopp.
- Kragen?
Kragen ist nice, tipptopp. So.
Bereit.
- Okay. Also.
Morgen. Wann haben Sie den Termin?
- Ich habe ihn um ...
... 8.40 Uhr.
Was bedeutet das für Sie?
- Es ist aufregend.
Weil man von vielen Leuten hört,
die sich nicht impfen lassen wollen.
Sie sagen, man sei eine Testperson.
Aber auf der Welt
wurde schon so viel geimpft,
dass das erprobt und gut ist,
dass das eine gute Sache ist,
sich impfen zu lassen.
Ich drücke den Daumen.
- Danke schön.
Vielen Dank, bis später.
- Sie dürfen zum Kollegen.
Auf Wiedersehen! Wie viele hast du?
- Du kannst alle durchlassen.
Kritische Stimmen zum Impfen
höre ich im Impfzentrum keine.
Hier sind alle froh,
dass sie kommen dürfen.
9.10 Uhr.
So, wir gehen auffüllen.
Ja, ist gut. Achtung, ich übernehme.
So.
- Gut.
Der Moderna-Impfstoff
sei nicht heikel.
Er kann in einem normalen Kühlschrank
gelagert werden.
Wie viel habt ihr gekriegt?
Ähm ... Wir haben 150 Fläschchen
gekriegt, das sind 1'500 Dosen.
D.h., der Kühlschrank, wie er da
ist, reicht für eine gute Woche.
Das ist der grosse Kampf:
Alle wollen die Impfungen.
Ich habe gehört,
einer habe offenbar versucht,
beim Impfen
eine zweite Spritze zu stehlen.
Ja, er wurde dabei ertappt,
weil sie ihm zur Tasche rausfiel.
Ja ... So etwas lässt sich nicht
zu 100 % vermeiden.
Wie sehen die Prognosen aus?
Das Ziel war ursprünglich,
bis zum Sommer
einen grossen Teil geimpft zu haben.
Das erreichen wir nicht.
- Das wird sicher schwierig.
März, April, Mai wird es wohl
so weitergehen, wie bis jetzt.
Man erwartet
erst ab Mai, Juni, Juli mehr -
vorausgesetzt, wir kriegen einen
oder zwei zusätzliche Impfstoffe.
Von meiner Truppe, dem Zivilschutz,
gehen nächste Woche alle
in ihr eigenes Leben zurück.
Und du? Was hast du für Aussichten?
Wie lange ...
Ich weiss es so wenig, wie wir das
mit der Impfstoffsicherheit wissen.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass uns das
noch einige Monate begleiten wird,
bis es vielleicht dann mal
für alle besser und leichter ist.
Es gibt einen Stich.
Geht es für Sie?
- Ja.
Schon fast fertig.
Es gibt einem schon
eine gewisse Sicherheit.
Und es ist auch
wegen den Angehörigen,
wenn sie jeweils kommen.
Es ist einem ja nicht egal ...
... wenn sie dann etwas auflesen.
Sie können reinschlüpfen.
Ich helfe Ihnen kurz.
Auf Wiedersehen. Eine gute Zeit.
Auf Wiedersehen.
- Ade miteinander.
Ah, jetzt sehen wir uns wieder!
Wie war es?- Ja, harmlos.
Mega gut.
- Ich habe natürlich ...
... mit meiner Vorerkrankung
schon etwas Angst.
In einem Monat
ist es mir sicher wohler.
Man ist nicht mehr so gehemmt.
Das ist meine Hoffnung.
Wir dürfen die Hoffnung
auch nicht verlieren.
Das ist das Wichtigste.
Solange die Gesundheit da ist
und wir gesund bleiben
und auch wirklich positiv
im Leben weitergehen
und das positiv sehen,
strahlen wir selbst Positivität aus.
Wenn wir alle so ...
... eingeengt sind,
wird das nicht besser.
Von wegen nicht so laufen ...
Kopf hoch,
sonst fällt die Krone runter.
Das sagt man doch.
- Genau.
Also, Kopf hoch,
sonst fällt die Krone runter.
Das ist gut, genau. Ade.
- Vielen Dank.
Bis in einem Monat.
Bleiben Sie gesund!
Eine gute Zeit. Ade.
- Danke.
Zuversichtlich bleiben
und v.a. Geduld haben.
Das ist  d e r  Beitrag,
den alle von uns leisten können -
wie Nico, Nderim, Aline,
Markus und Lukas Wopmann
und alle anderen,
die sich im Impfzentrum engagieren,
damit unser Leben
bald wieder normaler wird.
Also, einen schönen Abend. Danke.
- Mach's gut. Tschau.
Dies nehme ich mit
von den drei Tagen:
Bewältigen können wir die Pandemie
nur miteinander.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021